do we have any alternates that need to
be seated to representative Broda
I'm sorry yes
um Senator Whitley will not be here so
correct you can sit in for Senator
Whitley
okay
[Music]
um the minutes of the previous meeting
Madam chair I move approval of minutes
Supreme meeting second
representative Schmidt
changes are comment all right seeing
none those in favor
aye those opposed
no not a post okay
the consent agenda
is are there any bills to any excuse me
rules to be removed from a consensus
agenda um I did want to let you guys
know that on page two of the consent
agenda letter O uh 2022 149 that's
actually a conditional approval
it just is in the wrong place so oh so
the board of psychologists is a
conditional approval request yes okay
no nobody's taking anything
okay is there a second second
all right any discussion
those in favor
aye opposed
all right that's what's been sent agenda
and thanks I'd like to thank the staff
for making sure it was as long as
possible
all right regular agenda
Health and Human Services
okay so I'm going to talk about these
two proposals together
um
2022-99 and 100 both of these are
radiation safety proposals they deal
with licensing and radiation safety
requirements and they were previously
postponed from the November meeting
after some after some discussion by the
committee there was only one issue that
remained and that was an issue with the
fiscal impact statement the rule
amendments added of requirements by
inserting a citation within the rule and
um and that was to Hep
4038 but the agency's request for fiscal
impact to the LBA didn't inform the LBA
that the inclusion of those requirements
would not result in a fiscal impact
because the regulated entities were
basically already adhering to similar
requirements that were administratively
attached to as a condition on their
licensor by the federal government after
9 11.
the agency could not get an amended fist
because there was no they didn't meet
the statutory requirements to do so and
so after some discussion the committee
decided to postpone the agency requested
to postpone to January so that it could
have enough time to get together revised
fists for both of these
which isn't something really that's um
you know in 541a but they were able to
get two revised faces and both of those
are in the FP meeting packet at the end
of the packet
basically the LBA states that um the
cost if there are any would be
indeterminable
from additional necessary security
measures and but there could be some
benefits from securing the radioactive
materials from theft and from providing
additional protection against unintended
unintended radiation exposures anyway
way both of those two proposals have
those the revised associated with them
and I have no further comments
associated with the proposals
any questions or concern or comments
from the committee
okay do we need to hear from you agency
at all good morning sorry I wasn't sure
if you wanted me to introduce myself
Nicole valenzola Department of Health
and Human Services uh rules coordinator
you can
so do you have anything to add
uh no I'm here I'm happy to answer any
questions if you have any okay
Madam chair I move approval of 22.99 is
that good
further discussion
those in favor I opposed
Madam chair I move approval of 22 100.
listen those in favor I opposed
all right let's see you probably got the
easiest one of the day
other than the consent calendar
the board of veterinary medicine is
still working on theirs do we have a
motion to postpone second
any discussion on this this does not
need a waiver because we're postponing
it to the February meeting that's
correct okay so discussion those in
favor
aye
opposed
okay
thank you very much that's postponed
Department of Justice
this is a new one
thank you these are the uh justice 1600
procedures for pharmaceutical drug
collection and Disposal program uh
currently there are five substantive
comments that remain on this particular
proposal the note to jail car on page
seven the agency did submit the rest of
their incorporation by reference
statements so that no longer applies
but the first substantive comment
appears on page one
this is a definition where there is a
requirement which is not in compliance
with the manual so therefore has to be
reworded
the second substitute comment if it's
rewording isn't that an editorial
comment the reason we had it as an
unclear editorial comment is because
this same comment was made on the
initial proposal and the agency did not
change it so we did have concerns that
there was a reason that it wasn't
changed
oh thank you
the next substantive comment appears on
page two and page three of the rule the
agency
states that the
law enforcement officer who is proposing
to have uh a Take Back event or a
permanent box needs to get permission
from the DEA and they cite to a federal
rule however that rule simply lays out
when this may happen and gives the
states the ability to do it it does not
state that the agency or the excuse me
the law enforcement officer needs the
authorization of the DEA to do so
so there was an unclear comment on why
authorization is required from the daa
what particular statute or rule
requires that as staff could not find
that particular statute or Rule and
additionally what that authorization
will entail which ties into the unclear
comment on page five the section for
waiver requests it's unclear because if
the
law enforcement officer can waive a
request of the rule that calls them to
question whether or not that will affect
the authorization from the DEA yes the
final comment I'd like to hear from the
agency about this one because
foreign
thank you madam chair Matthew Brodhead
here on I'm a senior Assistant Attorney
General I'm here on behalf of the
Attorney General this is a re-adoption
of the rules that have been existence
for 10 years
um with minor changes from stakeholders
uh law in the law enforcement Community
um I'll just if I could take those
comments just one at a time the initial
proposed rule as filed did not contain a
comment
um with respect to the definition I have
the copy of the initial proposals here
so the addition of the edit unclear with
respect to the definition of inner
lining is actually raised at the first
time in the final proposed text
um and that the if I might just explain
why it's worded that way this was a
comment actually from the uh then
outgoing police chief in the town of
Windham he had mentioned that there are
certain law enforcement officers that do
the best that they can in these drug
take back collection events but they
don't necessarily we collect them in
inner Linings they're consistent with
the DEA requirements so this definition
is uh nearly verbatim with the DEA
definition for drug take-back events and
so the reason why we just asked the
committee to adopt it as written would
be because we don't want to create
differing standards between the DEA
regulations and the state regulations it
would create unnecessary confusion
um and excuse me so this is the first
requirement that there be an inner
lining
this is a change in uh from the uh old
rule to the current rule the inner
lining
um provides what law enforcement
officers when they take evidence into
you know of a crime they have a sealed
evidence bag that's logged and you can
track if it's ever been tampered with
who's had access to it
um what this inner lining does is it
creates an industry standard just like
pharmaceutical
agencies uh you know CVS or your
standard drug take back locations it
brings them in line to that process so
that they're not just placing uh during
drug collection events uh unwanted
opioids into a trash bag that's then
stored on a shelf for a while so it does
create that level of um you know brings
it in line to evidence until it's
destroyed so this is a new requirement
on local uh communities that are chewed
using to have take back
it's a new requirement for those
communities who opt into it it's not a
mandatory program and the reason why the
waivers exist is for those communities
that are not able to comply for whatever
reason these bags are on retail for
Amazon for about ten dollars for a a
dozen or so
um and uh but yes it is a requirement
for those
single day take back events and for the
Standalone
pharmaceutical uh collection boxes
and again this is an opt-in program so
communities can choose to do it so we're
not unfortunately going to do mandate on
them that if they want to do that they
have to accept that this is part of the
process that's correct and I've got
statistics from the DEA actually that
were um that are from 2021 and there are
as the committee knows there are over
300 communities not in in the state of
New Hampshire but not all have their own
police departments but
um total law enforcement in the state of
New Hampshire is among the highest as
percentage of law enforcement population
we have 125 communities that took that
place and Drug take back days
um there's 128 locations for those uh
drug take back uh programs and in one
year New Hampshire has collected over
ten thousand pounds of uh of uh opioid
prescription drugs
um and that was the 2021 since the
adoption of this Rule and our
participation in the program New
Hampshire has collected over 192 000
pounds of illegal or expired
prescription drugs so this has been
heavily utilized in the community
um with respect to the comment so
excuse me we have another question
thank you madam Pierre you were
discussing a moment ago that not all
communities in New Hampshire have police
departments and I know that there are
some that where the state police
basically provides law enforcement what
if one of those communities wishes to uh
to take part in this program
do they uh how would they do that do
they just ask the state police and is
there some kind of an issue if if the
state police are are doing it because
they have a kind of a much larger range
of
Duty and Authority as well so could you
speak to that thank you representative
that's an excellent question State
Police has uh primary jurisdiction in
those communities that are under 3500 I
believe is the number it might be four
thousand
um and um in those communities that
where the select board wants to partake
in a drug take-back program and they are
able to utilize the resources at state
police and they would and state police
would provide a trooper for those
one-day uh take back programs it's
always an option for those communities
to reach out to the colonel or to the
troop commander in their area where
they'd be able to arrange for that to
happen
thank you and if I could just respond to
that very quickly yes represent
um first off I apologize about the
comment with the IP
um
and then secondly the reason that it's
an unclear is because if you are
planning on keeping that requirement it
will need to be placed somewhere else in
the rule we're not saying that it has to
be taken out it just cannot be in a
definition as that goes against the
manual looking at the rule if you want
to have the inner lining
requirement for permanent and for take
back programs those could be moved down
further in the rules specifically to
1603.01 for the permanent boxes just
throwing that in as a requirement and
then additionally
for 1604.02 just once again adding a
another paragraph to just have that
requirement in there instead of in the
definition
fine so so I think that that would be a
simple way to do it is to Simply move it
to what is a more appropriate place to
put that requirement is that agreeable
I can look at that I I
the reason why I push back slightly and
I I granted the rules on the rules are
clear
um I asked for an exception in this
instance just simply because the law
enforcement Community has a lot to
shoulder and when they look up the
definition of inner lining at the DEA
under the federal regulations they're
going to see these requirements that are
in the definition and that it needs to
be capable of being sealed immediately
I think it's more efficient frankly to
have the definition leave it the way it
is
understanding that you know we're not
trying to create unfair Surprise by
pigeonholing
or shoe warning a whatever the right
idiom is
um to into the definition uh you know
we're not trying to pull anything
um on it but
um by and large the community in the law
enforcement Community understands what
an inner lining is and that it requires
it to be sealed similar to an Evidence
jury bag
um okay but yeah I've obviously deferred
to the committee on that
um just uh in terms of the comment on
page two and then the subsequent
comments to throughout initially our
initial proposed rule did not have the
CFR reference we provided the CFR
reference in response to a comment on
our initial proposed rule that said you
know insert the CFR so we did insert the
CFR it's actually it could be improved
by saying it's the chapter it's 21 CFR
chapter 1317. the reason is that you
have to register the location of every
collection uh take back program with the
DEA they need to certify that there is a
in fact a location
um that where these events are occurring
or where the Dropbox is occurring and
that's not there's not it's not cited at
any particular point in the CFR so I
could not provide a particular CFR where
that is but it hinges on the definition
of registered location and it hinges on
a couple different areas where law
enforcement has the authority to to
participate in these take back locations
representative Schmidt
thank you madam chair so you reference
drop boxes so would there be
circumstances in which a Dropbox is is
uh provided and there's no individual no
law enforcement person there to monitor
or in in other words somebody could come
and not only
drop off but also but potentially take
that is that is a possibility that the
Dropbox will be unattended yes and
they've they've um accounted for that
because the rules for Dropbox are much
more dropboxes are much more strict they
need to be located on the premises of
the actual police station or the law
enforcement location it needs to be
under video surveillance there are
um uh certain bolting mechanisms the
actual canister itself can't be tampered
with or accessed
these have been for the communities that
can that have the resources to to
support these drop boxes
they are uh
very effective because people who may
have an addiction problem don't
necessarily feel safe enough to go and
face a law enforcement officer face to
face to admit that and so having those
locations where they could be dropped
off anonymously is an important resource
to the community well thank you for that
clarification that really helps to
understand how it works thank you
peace if I I have a question if
do we understand you correctly say that
there's no
clear definition in the federal rules as
to how they would reply to a request or
notification from a police department
um no the the written authorization
piece
just is a review on the part of the DEA
to make sure that the location
requirements satisfy the DEA rules
for either drop boxes or one day take
back events
um so how do they get back to the New
Hampshire police
to officer making this request
how do they contact them yeah I mean how
it sounds from what you say it sounds as
though
police
request this approval or notify the DEA
and then they can't do anything until
they receive authorization
how is that authorization provided
that's a good question I don't know the
specifics whether it's a phone call or
whether it's a written correspondence
back I'm happy to find that answer out I
I don't know the mechanism for how they
give the feedback to the location I hope
it's not a phone call because our our
rule specifically says written
authorization so
um
yeah I don't know I don't know how they
do it but uh you think that that that's
an acceptable thing to to have in our
requirements I do
um and
and here's kind of this is a that that
provision has been in for the last 10
years we had a robust reach out this is
a joint rule making Authority with the
uh the department of safety uh the
Department of Environmental Services and
the pharmaceutical board we've reached
out to all stakeholders on this we
reached out to the chiefs of Police
Association Chief Becky provided
feedback that this is a program that's
working it's well understood in the
community and that particular
authorization requirement when we had
our public comment period was not
something that was that ever came up
I'm glad to hear that
any other questions before we go on to
the next comment
okay
the last comment is an unclear comment
on page six of the rules
um this section lays out an alternative
procedure
for
having a take back program
this comment was also made when these
rules came before the committee back in
2012 they were adopted with this
particular part included however we make
the comment again that
if there is already a procedure to waive
the rules what is the need for an
alternate procedure and additionally
back to the comment with regard to the
waiver how would that affect the
authorization from the DEA
thank you so I was able to pull the
letter that was addressed from the then
administrative rules director uh who
oversaw this process with the original
car approval and that section 1608 was
originally titled exemptions
and the jail car comment was to change
that heading to Alternative procedures
it
there there's two programs that are
authorized by the DEA
um excuse me one program with two
Alternatives and that is uh what we've
adopted here it gives the maximum amount
of flexibility to the local communities
that can't maintain a permanent Dropbox
that it gives them the opportunity to
have these one day take back collection
events which is what you see in 1608 it
is by far and large the most preferred
option by the local communities and the
rule to the extent there's
um you know in terms of the the statute
what it says is that it authorizes the
Department of Justice and these in
conjunction with these other agencies to
adopt rules to clarify what programs
would be available and we've outlined
two non-mutually exclusive programs an
agency can set up a Dropbox and they can
also have a take back program uh it
gives maximum flexibility to the
communities
so the alternative is actually in the D
the federal rules and so we're complying
with one section or the other
correct the um the rule is uh 21 CFR 13
17.35 and it authorizes specifically for
law enforcement officers to engage in
take back events
or collection receptacles located inside
law enforcement's physical address okay
so
yeah that might seems clear to me any
other questions comments yes
representative Leon thank you madam
chair
um it appears to me that there's also
the one-time um one-time procedures in
rule 1604 is that a different one
that has the it's titled periodic or
one-time pharmaceutical drug take-back
events yes so to the extent that there's
the program that's been established and
say there's uh you know uh shortage a
lot of law enforcement communities this
is a good example are experiencing a
shortage of officers so to the extent
that they still want to participate in a
community Take Back event and that they
can't have two officers present for the
actual Take Back event at all times they
can request a waiver at the doj to uh
uh you know wave that one that
two-person requirement
um
what would be helpful is with this Inner
Line lining uh addition is that it would
actually enable uh uh more communities
to have one person because it would
double uh secure whatever uh drugs are
taken back to the extent that there's a
tamper-proof inner lining with one
officer that doubly that then make sure
that there's uh no foul play that could
be had
thank you
um so it has the normal procedure with
two officers in 1604 which then would
need a waiver which is 1607 and then is
1608 an entirely different alternative
that doesn't require a waiver in order
to fit into that one officer and
tamper-proof liner
see I'm sorry say that one more time so
the standard Community take back day is
1604 and you said they may need a waiver
which is 1607.
and then we have the alternative
procedure at 1608 is 1608 just codifying
one of those differences with the one
officer and the tamper-proof lining
I'm sorry I don't think I understand
your your question can you say it one
more time
we have one day take back some 1604
which can have a waiver through 1607.
um then then I don't know if that would
handle your one officer or if that's
just a separate codification of it I'm
I'm sorry so to uh to confuse you yes so
um
the
the the 1608
procedure is are those entities that are
providing
um
uh that are solely governed by the DEA
procedure and where there's preemption
so that and that's my fault and I'm
sorry to cause confusion so where there
where there is an entity uh or a law
enforcement officer that is specifically
designated by the DEA to conduct at the
request of the federal government
through their own Federal delegation
these rules are generally not applicable
anyways they'd be preempted but what
this provides is that is if you're
acting pursuant to a DEA Authority that
to follow the federal mandates
I'm sorry for the confusion there thank
you for that clarification thank you
that is not clear that
the because it looks it looked to me
like you've got
you know two percent the standard the
one at a time procedure and then the
with waiver options and then you have a
totally separate thing right and I think
that's why it was originally titled as
an exemption and not alternative
procedure
um when the jail car originally was
presented with this rule it was it there
was so this was different completely so
1608 is an alternative procedure for
essentially non-law enforcement entities
no it's for law enforcement entities
that are designated by the DEA to to act
in accordance with federal law
I think that that should be indicated
somewhere that it is specific there are
only specific law enforcement agencies
that can use this because this reads
like
um
you know if my town decides to set one
up they could use this procedure and
apparently they can't because I'm sure
we're not on the list of specific
authorizations happy to clarify that
okay thank you I think the title would
be the place to put it
any other questions Madam chair Brokers
on the Block Senator that's fine
um so two things
um I I am too also confused by three
different programs that are that are
listed and who is responsible for which
one and who's eligible to use which one
but I am not unclear on the inner lining
conversation I guess I just want to just
go back to that first conversation point
we had about inner Linings because if
you look at the definition right above
inner Linings it's a def it's a Dropbox
and dropbox says it has to have an inner
lining and then the next one is just a
definition of when inner lining is so
they know what has to go in there so
they don't use a Shaw's bag right so I
guess that's the best way I can say is
I'm not I'm okay with the definitions as
they are it just cleans up exactly
what's in the definition above that says
a Dropbox has to have it in her bag and
then their bag is and it tells it what
an inner bag is so agreed right
okay
um
so I is there any other question any
other comments discussions questions
no no
in that case I think I will move move to
approve conditionally that
the heading for
Justice 1608 specify that is only for
previously approved law enforcement
agencies or something
for specific law enforcement agencies
designated by the DEA
second
any further discussion
okay those in favor hi
those opposed
thank you very much
thank you very much for your time
Board of Education Board of Education
um so I'm looking at the conditional
approval for 2022 138
on page two all the page numbers say one
but there's only three pages so
um
and so I'm looking at a Ed
150105 paragraph C
um so this is the only issue and it and
um the paragraph reads if the department
finds the Innovation plan performance is
not improving at a sufficient rate
um so these are Innovation schools they
they come up with a plan and then the
Board of Education evaluates
um their progress
but improving at a sufficient rate is I
mean it lacks criteria it's you know
it's not clear enough for a person to
actually know what they need to do
um the second half of of what they added
there you know or that the plan is not
achieving the planned results is a
that has that's a criteria
um so you would know what you need to do
to make that happen but improving at a
sufficient rate just isn't clear enough
so
and I believe you're the department
ready to explain this to us hi good
morning
um Julie Shea Department of Education
um administrative rules coordinator
um hi I'm Elizabeth Brown I'm Council
for the Department
um
we we are um
happy to remove improving at a
sufficient rate so that it simply says
is not achieving the planned results
um that is covered in The Innovation
plan and that way
um there's no gray area of what a
sufficient rate is we don't want to
Define what a sufficient rate is because
the local school boards are the ones
that should be reviewing these plans and
we don't want to overstep that either
that would work okay
thank you that's uh
move to approve as edited thank you
any discussion
if those in favor
aye
opposed
okay thank you very much excellent thank
you great thank you
insurance
so this is 2022 163 on procedures and
adjusters the agency did file a
conditional approval request which
removed all but two comments
the first comment has appears on page
two of the rule the agency uses May
instead of shall
the agency had responded that this was
part of the model rule language and
therefore makes them exempt from having
to use the shell however in a
conversation with the agency's attorney
just now it seems there was a bit of a
miscommunication that language was
actually pulled from guidance not the
actual model rules so therefore our
comment would stand that this needs to
be changed to Shell
foreign
good morning I'm Heather Silverstein
general counsel at the New Hampshire
insurance department uh yes there was a
disconnect at my agency as far as model
rules and laws from the neic the
National Association of insurance
Commissioners as opposed to guidelines
and I did have a discussion with Rebecca
before this and we'd be it would be fine
to have shell instead of May so we can
change it okay thank you I'm chair move
to prove as edited okay any discussion
comments questions
I apologize I would draw my motion
trying to get this done so I didn't see
in a second I I thought that we allowed
the insurance department to follow
guidelines as well as model rules
I believe the exemption only is for the
model rules as opposed to the guidance
and just to be completely accurate this
is a handbook that came out from the
neic related to producer licensing so
um when I looked further down and had
the discussion with Rebecca my concerns
are alleviated I'm fine with shell hey
thank you please continue
the second substantive comment which is
found on page
four of the rule
um I also had a conversation
with Heather about this one as well
um the comment was not to remove the
citation for the statute but rather to
also include what the agency's
procedures are in determining what
penalty shall be given for whatever
action we understand it is factually
based but our suggestion was to just
cite to the insurance 200 rules which is
their adjudicative process to which it
sounds as though the agency is in
agreement with that
yeah so so
um having the conversation with Rebecca
this morning
um I would be fine I thought she wanted
us to remove the penalty statute
altogether which we do not want to do
um because we always defer to that in
our rules it's consistent and if that
statute ever changed we we just change
as a statute changes uh the rule changes
um so I would be amenable to adding
um uh an ins 200 as that applies and and
the reason I would like that
qualification is because
um it applies when there's a hearing and
so there could be a scenario where
there's no hearing and and as an example
of that let's say the producer uh
doesn't renew
um because they don't the license is not
removed because renewed because they
don't meet the educational requirements
but then they don't sell and then they
go go get their educational requirements
and then they submit that which is what
this rule is saying once you submit that
and you're in compliance then you're
fine the other scenario is a producer
doesn't renew doesn't meet the
educational requirements and keeps on
selling even though their license isn't
renewed that would trigger us to look
further into it and then that would end
up in administrative hearing and so
that's why I would rather have an ins
200 as that applies
thank you I think that's clear any other
comments no further comments
represent Senator Lang well tries again
move to approve with the edit says
presented
any further discussion comments
seeing none those in favor
aye opposed all right thank you very
much thank you
okay oplc natural scientists
so the only issue with this rule is that
um it some of it would uh excuse me
expired in March of 2019 and some of
those rules included display
disciplinary sanctions and
administrative fees and
some other things so you may have some
questions about that why yes
good morning good morning
um Madam chair members of the committee
for the record Lindsey Courtney
executive director office of
professional Ace insurance certification
um so I think the committee is well
aware of some of the challenges that
oplc has faced and our task and
plan to establish internal controls
within the agency we recently in
addition to
um coming up with a plan to ensure that
rules are not expiring which this is the
result of that
inventory that we conducted we also
inventoried all of the existing fees and
preparation for filing that you should
be seeing shortly to memorialize all
existing fees in one filing and
discovered that the fees had been
expired so that finding was made in
November so we're presently working on
the refunds that we are used to doing
unfortunately
in the past with fees expiring and the
lack of internal controls in the agency
I do think that with the filing that we
intend to make and I know we're working
on the fiscal impact statement right now
in the 1002s that that should remedy the
situation and prevent it from happening
in the future
happy to take any additional questions
it's better to be clear we the rules
expired we have collected fees we're
returning the fees because we didn't
have rules and we're ready to move
forward correct thank you move to
approve
any further come is there a second sorry
okay thank you are there any further
comments questions discussion
seeing none
those in favor I opposed
all right thank you very much
and court reporters
okay so 2022-9 for court reporters is an
interim rule
um which if adopted it will be effective
for 180 days this is on one of the
boards which was changed to an Advisory
Board to the executive director of the
oplc during the last legislative session
there are currently effective rules
which most likely are unenforceable
because the authority has been
transferred so if adopted there will be
two sets of rules effective however the
oplc does plan to repeal the currently
effective rules after adoption of these
rules
um besides that issue there are two
major issues to bring to your attention
and there are a couple of minor ones as
well
despite the filing of a conditional
approval request but those minor issues
can be handled during regular rule
making so for sake of time I'll just
discuss the two major issues the first
one is on page nine of the
FP package or page three of the rule
there is an issue of statutory conflict
and Authority that needs to be addressed
by the legislature and that's at PLC
1203.04 a
there you're going to see that the rule
is talking about the records of the
former board that they shall be retained
by the executive director in accordance
with the retention schedule scheduled
um established by the executive director
this language is what's in the statute
but there are two problems with it the
Authority for retention of state agency
records actually resides with the
Secretary of State the Department of
State which doesn't have any rules on
the topic so the statute is granting the
authority to the executive director and
that conflicts with other statutes the
second issue is that just merely Excuse
me yes I understand you correctly that
the problem is not with the rule but the
statutes partly the second part of this
particular section is that they're just
merely reciting what the statute says so
it doesn't provide any transparency for
how or how long or in what Manner the
rule the records will be maintained this
issue was in another proposal I think
recently before the committee and it was
approved but we felt like we need to
bring this to your attention because of
the staff statutory conflicts that need
to be resolved so that's the first major
issue I can pause there I'd like to say
on that that
we can address the issue of lack of
clarity and regular rulemaking in the
statutory conflict is somewhat beyond
agency's control if I may also interest
that Madam chair I don't view it as a
statutory conflict the intent of the
statute which authorizes the executive
director to establish a retention policy
was to make clear that the agency not
the boards could establish the retention
policy in accordance with the RSA
setting forth the requirement that the
Secretary of State approve the retention
policy because previously all of the
boards had their own retention policies
and it's very difficult for an agency to
execute 50 plus sets of retention
policies for the same types of documents
we did work with the Secretary of
State's office I would agree that it
would be nice if the procedures were a
little bit more transparent it took me
about a year to get that that uh that
retention policy approved but we do have
an approved retention policy pursuant to
the Secretary of State's Authority so I
don't view it as a conflict
they could and they could put some kind
of detail here you know around that
retention policy but again Madam chair
that could be done during regular
rulemaking whether that's five years or
however it is that they're retaining
that they could just kind of Flesh that
out a little bit more in the role
or they could simply provide a reference
to the oplc retention policy which is
somewhere available yes we can certainly
do that in regular rulemaking okay Madam
chair
um in this instance most agencies will
specify a period of years such as four
years and then we'll also say unless
otherwise establish pursuant to the
rules that are supposed to be adopted by
uh State I do plan to talk with the
Secretary of State about adoption of
those rules
thank you
okay the second major issue is on page
18 of the final proposal package or page
12 of the rule you can also look at page
three of the conditional approval
request here at PLC
1205.06 on documentation requirements
for audits the rule says that failure to
submit documents when told to do so
represents a rule violation for which
the executive director can take
disciplinary action as provided in the
rules and as provided in a cited statute
the problem is that using the phrase can
be taken violates the rules which
actually says later on that the
executive director shall impose
discipline
even if you ignore that the citation to
the PLC 1208 doesn't really work because
that section only describes the
aggravating and mitigating
factors for when determining what
discipline shall apply it doesn't
outline what the executive director will
consider whenever initiating the
discipline Additionally the citation to
the RSA 310 a174 doesn't really work
either because there's not a catch-all
category in the statute that would
directly apply it describes actions that
would be sufficient for incurring
discipline missing paperwork doesn't
really fall underneath those categories
it could possibly fall underneath
willful or repeated violations of the
statute that's a little bit of a stretch
so those are the two issues with this
proposal
I don't take issue with changing hand to
Shell
um I think that the result obviously
would be to eliminate discretion in
determining whether or not to discipline
an individual but I I support
I support having objective criteria and
I would be happy to change it to Shell
the
references to the
C
1208 and so forth can be fixed in a
regular rulemaking yes ma'am okay
any other concerns
no no ma'am questions comments given the
editorial comments I moved to approve
the interim interim Road
again
any further discussion
all right seeing none of those in favor
aye opposed
okay thank you very much
Medical Imaging
yes thank you madam chair so this rule
also was put in uh it's also an
intramural because the board has been
turned into an Advisory Board under the
oplc
the only two comments I had after the
oplc submitted conditional approval are
two that were just discussed on the
previous interim rule the issue with
other rules currently being in effect
under the old board it sounds like the
oplc is going to repeal those after
these rules are put into effect and the
other was for the retention policy which
we just had a discussion about I thought
that when we converted those boards to
advisory we put a general statement that
existing rules are valid until
expired or replaced we did not
um not in all instances that has
occurred I plan to talk with the direct
director of the conus and some of the
bill drafters about making a little more
uniform language uh because we've had
several instances
especially with the boards that are
becoming advisory boards and even back
to when puc was split into puc and
energy that they're always there has not
always been a clear definition of what
rules carried over
Etc I tried to put that in my uh oplc
organization bill that was the only
comment that I specifically add into it
is that the rules apply until uh
repealed or expired
I take a responsibility for that one I
should have noticed that when these were
going through
okay well I think we would have the same
visit editorial comments on this rule as
the previous one and um
same intent to clarify during regular
rulemaking so is there a motion
moved to approved yeah
excuse me
Lenny recovers move to approve the
interim rule
any further comments questions
all right seeing none of those in favor
aye
oh supposed all right yes I'm not
certain uh whether it was representative
Schmidt or representative guy in favor
of Representative
alphabetical ordering you know all right
so that completes our
business I think we will not have a
continued meeting this month
and is there any other business
there we go
Madam Madam chair I did send out an
email to all the members and alternates
yesterday indicating that because of the
weather we would not have a orientation
meeting today I did send out an
orientation packet that should cover
most everything but we would be happy to
meet with individual members or a group
of the members to go over that
okay I know at least one of the members
who's watching us on Zoom or whatever
streaming
method is so maybe some of the other
ones are as well because
uh I I was delighted to find out that
the roads from Dover to Concord were
very drivable but I looked out my window
this morning I thought hey
five inches of snow and who knows but
the roads are great so
yeah and thank you for efficiency we do
not have a continued meeting we will
meet in February on uh what day
17th
I just thought that should be in the
record there yeah
February 20th okay we will see you all
then